em
[Música]
casa tomar chimarrão
e
você pode mudar a vida de uma pessoa
apenas por ouvi-la
e você mulher no Brasil nunca foi fácil
uma pandemia mal geridas só piorou esse
cenário
no ano passado segundo a pesquisa
visível e invisível do Fórum Brasileiro
de Segurança Pública uma a cada quatro
mulheres brasileiras sofreram violência
e dessas dessas 25%
38 por cento sofreram violência sexuais
e portanto é muito provável que você
conheça alguma mulher que seja vítima o
que tenha sido vítima de violência mas
ao mesmo tempo é muito provável que você
não saiba que a sua amiga que a sua
vizinha o que a sua colega de trabalho
seja vítima de violência e isso acontece
porque o silêncio ainda é a resposta
mais prevalente que a sociedade impõe às
vítimas EA sobreviventes
Oi e o silêncio adoece o corpo EA mente
de pessoas que já passaram por
violências muito grandes e para que isso
não seja o destino de pessoas assim de
pessoas Sobreviventes é necessário que a
nossa sociedade
aprenda a escutar sem julgar
e eu aprendi a importância da escuta
quando eu precisei dela
amigas muito queridas como a Maria Maria
Renata me deram todo o apoio todo o colo
e toda a paciência quando eu estava no
relacionamento abusivo e eu tenho
certeza que foi esse acolhimento que
permitiu que eu consegui se transformar
o meu trauma em ação e percebendo a
relevância EA importância da escuta eu
decidi destinar parte da minha vida a
escutar Mulheres vítimas de violência
foi por meio da rede feminista de
juristas uma articulação que eu fundei
em 2016 com outras profissionais do
direito que eu conheci a escuta ativa
Oi e o quê que é a escuta ativa a escuta
Ativa é uma ferramenta de comunicação
e é uma ferramenta de comunicação que
tem algumas premissas a primeira delas é
é uma escuta interessada e o significa o
que significa que quando você está
escutando aquela pessoa você está
presente você não tá olhando o seu
celular você não tá olhando as horas
você não está dando sinais de
impaciência e de ansiedade o que ela
conversa acabe a escuta ativa também é
livre de julgamentos
você não vai revirar os olhos fazer
longo suspiro sou dar de ombros o mesmo
emitir opiniões né vocalizados de
julgamento Além disso na escuta ativa as
perguntas que são feitas tem como
objetivo apenas compreender aquilo que
está sendo falado pela pessoa que está
contando a história e nunca perguntas
para desafiar o franjer polemizar com
quem está contando a história e por fim
a escuta ativa ela é imparcial você não
está nem gelado e nem do outro você está
interessado interessado em compreender
como que a história contada impactou
quem está contando aquela história é mas
infelizmente a escuta ativa ela ainda é
muito pouco difundida seja na sociedade
em geral seja perante autoridades
responsáveis por apurações de violências
como polícias o mesmo as apurações
internas que acontecem no ambiente de
trabalho e eu acredito que a ausência da
escuta Ativa é um dos fatores que
explicam os elevados índices de
violência contra as mulheres no Brasil a
subnotificação desse tipo de violência a
existência de predadores sexuais insere
como a gente tem visto eclode nos
últimos tempos e também explica por que
que meninos que são abusados sexualmente
na infância costumam demorar em média 26
anos para contar para alguém que foram
vítimas de uma violência segundo a
organização portuguesa quebrar o
silêncio
o e bom
considerando que a gente não tem escuta
ativa e que quando uma pessoa
especialmente uma mulher vai reportar
uma violência ela vai ser confrontada
com mentiras e estigmas a respeito da
violência a partir por exemplo de
perguntas inadequadas a respeito do seu
comportamento Que roupa você tava usando
porque que você tava lá você tinha
bebido
essas perguntas reforçam a mentira o
mito de que a culpa é da vítima de que
teve a algo que ela fez ou deixou de
fazer que deu causa ao trauma que ela
agora Tá experimentando
Oi e aí a gente soma essa jornada da
sobrevivente com alguns dados levantados
pelo Fórum Brasileiro de segurança
pública no anuário de Segurança Pública
lançada em 2021 e o que que esses dados
nos revelam que a gente teve no Brasil
quase 61 mil estupros registrados em
de se você tem desses quase 61 mil
estupros
73,7 por cento deles né 174 por cento
deles foram cometidos contra pessoas
vulneráveis isso significa o quê pessoas
que não podiam nem consentir e nem negar
com o ato sexual
Além disso Quase 60 quase 61 por cento
desses estupros foram cometidos contra
meninas menores de 13 anos
em 87 por cento deles foram cometidos
contra mulheres contra pessoas do sexo
ou do gênero feminino e quase oitenta e
Seis por cento deles foram cometidos por
pessoas conhecidas
das vítimas
bom então é bastante certo nós afirmamos
que temos centenas de milhares ou até
mesmo milhões de meninas e mulheres
brasileiras
forçadas a conviver em silêncio com os
seus agressores porque elas não
encontraram respaldo nem emocional nem
no sistema de Justiça
Oi e esse cenário fica ainda mais grave
quando a gente sabe que esse número de
quase sessenta e um mil estupros
registrados
corresponde a mais ou menos dez porcento
dos casos que aconteceram os outros
noventa porcento ficam pra sempre fiz o
culto e corroendo a saúde mental e
física das sobreviventes
o e bom para que esse não seja o seu
destino é necessário que a gente aprenda
você se você fala inglês eu recomendo
que você Acesse o site da ren a rap
Bills Insight National Network uma
organização de mais de 30 anos fundada e
sediada nos Estados Unidos que já
atendeu mais de 3 milhões de vítimas
Além disso você pode buscar informações
nas redes do Mit o Brasil projeto do
qual eu Sou coordenadora você também
pode encontrar informações no site da
instituição portuguesa quebrar o
silêncio E além disso o livro Ela disse
que é o livro que conta a história da
reportagem que eclodiu o escândalo de
hardwares e nos Estados Unidos dando
origem ao mito e o documentário a origem
do trauma é um documentário canadense de
um médico
Ah e por quê que é importante que a
gente Saiba escutar e ouvir porque a
Sobreviventes elas passam por uma série
de sintomas como ansiedade
síndrome do pânico
abuso de álcool e droga medo de tecer
novas relações
dificuldade de permanecer no trabalho e
portanto perda de renda e esses sintomas
devido à falta de apoio institucional
social e mesmo pessoal
eles demoram a passar e as pessoas ao
redor da sobrevivente começam a perder a
paciência
aí você ainda tá assim você não vai
melhorar nunca isso não vai passar
se importanto eu uso esse espaço para
que a gente possa trocar e eu possa
contribuir um pouco com informações
vindas do meu conhecimento técnico e
prático porque hoje eu formo o pessoas
que atendem vítimas e Sobreviventes para
que esse atendimento não re cause Novas
Novas utilizações nenhum novos traumas
bom se alguma pessoa te procurar para te
contar a respeito de uma violência que
ela sofreu você nunca deve dizer frases
como
mas onde é que você tava com a cabeça
estando lá sozinha
o ou ainda Você tem certeza que foi isso
que aconteceu
Você não tá confundindo
e não impossível eu conheço ele ele
jamais seria capaz de cometer uma coisa
dessa
Que bom pelo menos ou foi alguma coisa
tão grave
E essas frases Muitas delas carregadas
de boas intenções na verdade elas causam
um novo trauma na medida em que elas
deixam implícito que teve algo que a
vítima fez ou deixou de fazer para que
aquilo que aconteceu com ela acontecesse
E além disso elas reduzem diminui de
maneira Leviana o que aquela pessoa está
sentindo
se você ao contrário Então pode
substituir essas frases por algumas
outras que eu deixo como exemplo aqui
eu não faço ideia do que você está
passando Mas eu estou aqui por você
muito obrigada por confiar em mim para
contar a sua história Afinal gente essa
provavelmente vai ser a conversa mais
difícil que essa pessoa vai ter
E você também pode dizer coisas como o
que você gostaria de fazer agora
ou eu estou aqui pelo tempo que você
precisar eu me interesso pelo que você
tem a dizer como que eu posso te ajudar
essas frases ao contrário das anteriores
elas reconhecem que aquilo que está
sendo o caos contado tem muito valor
para aquela pessoa e além disso reforça
o senso de autonomia de pertencimento e
de conexão daquela pessoa com a sua
comunidade elementos que já são sabidos
pela ciência como essenciais para a
recuperação de um trauma um trauma pode
ser um episódio da qual a pessoa se
recupera ou pode ser um definidor de
vida e para que ele não seja um
definidor de vida é importante que a
gente nos que a gente Seduc porque essas
situações de conf e elas nos lançam
automaticamente fora da nossa zona de
conforto e além disso nos confrontam com
os nossos próprios preconceitos com as
nossas próprias barreiras e eu tenho
certeza que todas as pessoas querem ser
agente de apoio de afeto e de amor para
os outros
escutar relatos como foi essencial que a
minha mãe acreditasse em mim
ou ainda
escutar relatos como
E aí
é a minha família ficou mais unida
depois que os meus pais pediram
desculpas para mim e que eles passaram a
me respeitar sobre aquilo que tinha
acontecido
e pessoas que se ofereceram para serem
testemunhas de um processo
pessoas que se ofereceram para encontrar
apoio jurídico para que ela vítima apoio
jurídico-feminista do melhor tipo
pessoas que evitaram julgar e avaliar
como que aquela pessoa estava passando
por aquela situação
São pessoas que transformam as vidas da
Sobrevivência não há reação correta o
choro compulsivo ou até mesmo a
impassibilidade diante do que aconteceu
são reações possíveis e devem ser
respeitadas
escutar Os relatos é extremamente
gratificante porque você percebe o
impacto que você teve como aquilo de
impacto também
e pela vida de todas as meninas e
mulheres brasileiras a culpa nunca é da
vítima muito obrigada